Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. Or, if you're listening on the Apple Podcasts app, you can subscribe within the app in just a few clicks. For Alfred, the next few days were like some terrible dream. He could barely remember how he and his bodyguards had got out of the hall,
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听加更节目、抢先体验、无广告音频并加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。或者，如果您使用的是 Apple Podcasts App，只需点击几下即可在应用内订阅。对阿尔弗雷德来说，接下来的几天就像是一场可怕的噩梦。他几乎记不清自己和保镖们是如何逃出大厅的，
staggering desperately into the snow, stumbling through the night, freezing and frightened, and yet somehow thank the Lord still alive. That first night they kept moving until sunrise before taking shelter in a farmer's shed. Alfred fell asleep instantly and by the time he woke, hungry and shivering, the light was fading. For the next few days they moved only after dark. They scavenged for food, found shelter at dawn and slept until twilight before shaking themselves awake to resume their journey. Eventually the landscape began began to change the hills flattened out the ground was becoming boggier marshier that dominic as you will well know because you wrote
他们绝望地踉跄着冲进雪中，在夜色中跌跌撞撞，冻得瑟瑟发抖、惊恐万分，但不知为何，感谢上帝，他们居然还活着。头天晚上，他们马不停蹄地行军直到日出，随后才在一个农夫的棚屋里避难。阿尔弗雷德倒头便睡，等他醒来时，又饿又冷，天色已经暗了下来。接下来的几天里，他们只在夜间赶路。他们四处搜寻食物，黎明时寻找藏身处，一直睡到黄昏，然后把自己摇醒，继续赶路。最终，地貌开始发生变化，丘陵变得平缓，地面也变得越来越泥泞、潮湿，多米尼克，正如你所熟知的——因为你写过
that immortal prose um is from your new book fury of the vikings the latest in your splendid uh series adventures in time and it describes the escape of alfred in early january 878 from the treacherous viking ambush on chippenham he has no choice but to flee and he ends up in the what the anglicist action chronicle calls the fen fastnesses of athelny uh the prince's island in the somerset levels which now now, of course, is prime farmland because they've all been drained. But back then was very, very treacherous, boggy, watery, and therefore a perfect hiding place. And so that is where he takes shelter. So just for those people who have forgotten, as if you could, we're talking about the life of
那些不朽的篇章，呃，出自你的新书《维京人的愤怒》（Fury of the Vikings），这是你精彩的“时间历险”系列的最新一部——它描述了阿尔弗雷德在 878 年 1 月初逃离奇本汉（Chippenham）阴险的维京人伏击的情景。他别无选择，只能逃跑，最后到了盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史中所称的阿瑟尔尼（Athelny）沼泽据点，呃，也就是萨默塞特平原上的王子岛。现在，当然，那里已经是优质农田了，因为它们都被排干了。但在当时，那里非常非常危险，到处是泥沼和积水，因此是一个完美的藏身之处。所以，那就是他避难的地方。因此，对于那些已经忘记的人来说——仿佛你们能忘一样——我们正在谈论的是
Alfred the Great and his battles against the Vikings, his role in creating England and England's history. So Alfred was born in 849, wasn't he, Tom? He has been king since 871. It's now 878, as you say. And frankly, at this moment, you would think he's not going to be king much longer because he's had to flee into these sort of sodden marshes, as you say, the Somerset levels. He's been taken completely by surprise. It's clearly very hard for him to communicate with the rest of Wessex, with his kind of thanes and his eldermen. Because we're told that the Vikings spill out over Wessex. So they're seizing all this prime land.
大王阿尔弗雷德的一生，以及他对抗维京人的战争，他在缔造英格兰和英格兰历史方面所扮演的角色。所以，阿尔弗雷德出生于 849 年，对吧，托马斯？他自 871 年以来一直担任国王。如你所说，现在是 878 年。坦白说，此时此刻，你会觉得他当不了多久的国王了，因为正如你所说，他不得不逃进萨默塞特平原那种湿漉漉的沼泽里。他完全被打了个措手不及。显然，他很难与韦塞克斯的其他地方、与他的那些塞恩（thanes）和长老们（eldermen）取得联系。因为我们听说维京人涌入了韦塞克斯。所以他们占领了所有这些上好的土地。
And they think this is their moment. They haven't managed to kill him at Chippenham. He has escaped. But his defeat, as the Vikings would see it, is probably only a matter of time. You know, they'll catch up with him. Or he'll be betrayed. Or he'll flee. He'll flee. So that's what the King of Mercia has done.
他们认为这是他们的时刻。他们没能在奇本汉杀了他。他逃脱了。但正如维京人所认为的那样，他的战败可能只是时间问题。你知道，他们会追上他的。或者他会被背叛。或者他会逃跑。他会逃跑的。麦西亚国王就是这么做的。
Or he'll be captured. And that's what happened to the Northumbrian kings and Edmund, the King of East Anglia. And their fates were notoriously horrible. So it's he can defy the Danes, is, of course, the setting for one of the most famous stories in the whole of English history, Alfred and the Cakes. It is. So the story goes, isn't it, that after several days, he and what must presumably be a very small band of bodyguards, retainers, who knows, that they pitch up at the hut of a swineherd and his wife who don't recognize him. I mean, why would they recognize him? They can probably tell that he's somebody, perhaps from his clothes, but he's presumably covered in mud, shivering, miserable, not in
或者他会被俘虏。这就是诺森布里亚诸王和东盎格利亚国王埃德蒙的下场，而他们的命运是出了名的悲惨。因此，他能够对抗丹麦人，这当然是整个英格兰历史中最著名的故事之一的背景，也就是阿尔弗雷德烧焦烤饼。确实如此。故事是这样的，不是吗，几天后，他和一小群保镖、随从（天知道到底有多少人）来到了一个猪倌和他的妻子的茅屋，他们认不出他来。我的意思是，他们怎么可能认出他来？他们或许能从他的衣服看出他是个大人物，但他想必浑身是泥、瑟瑟发抖、痛苦不堪，并没有
the mood for great banter. And so the story goes, I mean, the story that you'll see in every in almost every book of english history is that the swineherd goes out to mind his pigs or whatever he's doing his wife is needing little cakes of bread so they're not kind of you know fruit cakes or something not mr kipling exactly and she puts them by the hearth to to. She lays them out and she says to Alfred, who's just sitting there staring into space, very miserable, you know, feeling sorry for himself. Well, surely feeling sorry for his people. Of course, Tom, sorry.
开玩笑的心情。于是故事是这样的——也就是你在几乎每一本英格兰历史书里都能看到的故事——猪倌出去照看他的猪或者做他正在做的事，他的妻子则在揉面团做小面包，所以它们不是那种，你知道的，水果蛋糕之类的，绝对不是吉卜林先生（Mr. Kipling）的蛋糕——她把它们放在炉边，放在那儿。她把它们摆好，然后对正坐在那里发呆、极其痛苦、自怨自艾的阿尔弗雷德说——嗯，当然是在为他的臣民感到难过，托马斯，抱歉。
I know I'm not, I should have known better than to be disrespectful about Alfred the Great. She goes out and she says, mind the cakes. He is thinking only of his kingdom and of God, isn't he? That's the trouble. Thinking of his people. Yes, thinking of his people. As you said in the last episode, he would make a very, very poor contender in the Great
我知道我不该——我本该懂得知分寸，不该对大王阿尔弗雷德不敬。她走出去，说道：“看好烤饼。”他满脑子想的都是他的王国和上帝，不是吗？这就是问题所在。想着他的臣民。是的，想着他的臣民。正如你在上一集里所说的，如果去参加《英国烘焙大赛》，他绝对会是一个非常非常糟糕的竞争者，因为当猪倌的妻子走进来时，烤饼已经烧焦了。它们变得焦黑。她用扫帚敲他的脑袋，对吧？这就是你总能在画面中看到的场景。她极其愤怒，她才不管他是谁，她只是对这家伙烧焦了这些烤饼感到无比愤怒。所以你觉得这是真的吗？绝对是的，是的，嗯，不，我是说，谁知道呢？我希望它是真的，如果这是（你知道的）我的红线，这就是我作为历史学家愿意为之战死的山头：阿尔弗雷德绝对烧了烤饼。你觉得呢，托马斯？我是说，这到底是——但实际上，这到底是一个什么样的故事？你认为这个故事的含义是什么？
British Bake Off, because when the swineherd's wife comes back in, the cakes are burning. They're blackened. And she beats him around the head with a broom, doesn't she? That's always the scene that you always get. She absolutely furious she has you know she doesn't care who he is she's just absolutely outraged that he has burned these cakes so do you think this is true definitely yeah definitely um well no i mean who who knows i want it to be true and if this is the you know this is my red line this is the hill on which i will die as a historian that that alfred definitely did burn the cakes what do you think tom i mean what's it but actually what's what's it a story about what's the meaning of the story do you think i
我认为这是可能的，嗯，它是——所以这是10世纪末的传说，所以它是那种可能会代代相传的轶事。但在中世纪文学中，微服私访的国王是非常受欢迎的人物。确实如此，所以这就是为什么人们会说这只是一种传统的故事。是的，但这些故事之所以受欢迎，是因为它们非常戏剧化；你也可以同样说，这个故事之所以被记住，是因为它是一个戏剧化的故事。所以我未必会认为——我觉得，好吧，就当作我们认为它是真的吧，托马斯。是的，就当作我们认为它是真的。让我们表明立场。但是，多米尼克，还有一个关于阿尔弗雷德在阿瑟尔尼（Athelny）期间的故事，不是吗？那个故事其实要激动人心得多。
think it's possible um well it's so it's late 10th century um so it's the kind of anecdote that might be passed down but kings in disguise are very popular figures in medieval literature they are and so that's that's why people say this is just a kind of traditional tale yeah but those stories are popular because they're so dramatic and you could equally say well this story was remembered because it was a dramatic story so i wouldn't necessarily be poet i think well let's say we think it's true tom yeah let's say let's say we think it's true. Let's put Pinnaculus to the mast. But Dominic, there's another story, isn't there, about Alfred's time on Athelni that is actually much more stirring.
嗯，你大概会觉得它更激动人心吧，这样说算公允吧？所以我们已经在关于圣卡斯伯特（St. Cuthbert）的那集节目中提到过这个故事了。是的。阿尔弗雷德再次展现出他并没有沮丧，因为阿尔弗雷德从不沮丧，但他正在苦思冥想如何拯救他的臣民。
Well, you would find it more stirring, I think it's fair to say, wouldn't you? So we have already mentioned this story in our episode on St. Cuthbert. Yeah. That Alfred, again, he's not moping because Alfred doesn't mope, but he's pondering ways to redeem his people.
与此同时，他所有的塞恩（thanes）都出去捕鱼了，但他却在苦思冥想如何拯救他的臣民。与此同时，他所有的塞恩都出去捕鱼了，但他们一条鱼也抓不到，因为河里似乎空空如也。他们剩下的食物已经不多了。一个老人出现了，他的头上盖着一件斗篷，向阿尔弗雷德讨要一些食物。于是阿尔弗雷德因为心地善良，把剩下的所有食物都给了他。那个人吃掉了食物。那个戴着斗篷的人离开了。阿尔弗雷德的手下回来了，带回了满载而归的鱼。他们突然开始捕到大量的鱼。这全都是好消息。
And meanwhile, all his thanes are off trying to fish, but he's pondering ways to redeem his people. And meanwhile, all his thanes are off trying to fish, but they can't get any fish because the rivers seem to be empty. They don't have much food left. An old man appears, his head covered with a cloak, and he asks Alfred for some food. And so Alfred, because he's so noble, gives him all the remaining food. The person eats it. And the man with the cow goes off. Alfred's men come back, absolutely freighted with fish. Suddenly they've started catching enormous amounts of fish. This is all great news.
阿尔弗雷德对此深感震撼。然后那天晚上他做了一个梦。那个戴斗篷的人显露了真身，原来他不是别人，正是伟大的圣卡斯伯特，他在林迪斯法恩（Lindisfarne）的神社曾遭到维京人的袭击。他一直是一位诺森布里亚的圣徒，但现在他表明自己同时也是撒克逊人、即西撒克逊人的守护神。他向阿尔弗雷德保证一切都会好起来的，他会捕到许许多多绝佳的鱼。所以这很好，他将要——他将要击败维京人，保持坚强和勇敢，卡斯伯特说，你的后代将成为英格兰的国王和全阿尔比恩（Albion）的统治者。是的，我的意思是，
And Alfred is very struck by this. And then that night he has a dream. And the cowed man reveals himself to be none other than top saint kuffbutt whose shrine at lindisfarne had been sat by the vikings always been an orthumbrian saint but he now reveals himself as a patron of of the saxons as well of the west saxons and he assures alfred that everything's going to be great he's going to get loads of fabulous fish so that's good he's um he's going to defeat the vikings and stay strong and courageous cuff but says and your descendants will be kings of england and rulers of all albion yes i mean
这基本上是一个有趣的转折，不是吗？他们不只是英格兰的国王，他们还将成为整个大不列颠的国王。是的，整个不列颠。所以这个故事，这几乎肯定是真实的吧，托马斯？那是当然的。你不会凭空编造这种事。不，绝对不会。另一个同样真实的关于这段时期的故事是：多米尼克，在第一部分中，你把一个维京人营地描述为一种非常非常可怕的音乐节。是的。据说阿尔弗雷德实际上乔装成了一名吟游诗人，走进了营地。
that's basically the interesting twist isn't it they won't just be kings of england but they'll be kings of all of great britain yeah the whole of britain and so this story this is almost definitely true isn't it tom that? Of course it's true. You wouldn't make up something like that. No, definitely not. And another story that's true also that is told of this period. Dominic, in part one, you described a Viking camp as being a kind of very, very frightening music festival. Yes. And Alfred actually dresses up, it is said, as a minstrel and goes off into the camp.
并潜入维京人营地，探听了他们所有的秘密。他进行弹唱演出，他们非常喜欢，纷纷围过来听他最新的热门歌曲，而他收集到了所有情报——这绝对是真实发生过的，托马斯。事实上，当我在写我的儿童读物时，我——我必须坦白，我把这个故事漏掉了。哦，为什么？因为它看起来太难以置信了。我的意思是，它看起来——这太像沃尔特·斯科特（Walter Scott）的风格了，不是吗？你敢信吗，我写了烧饼，我甚至写了卡斯伯特，但我决定在“吟游诗人潜入维京营地”这件事上划清界限。我还觉得这定错了……因为我追求的是一种非常丘吉尔式的基调。乔装成吟游诗人未免太矫情了吧？太像埃罗尔·弗林（Errol Flynn）了。是的，街头卖艺太像埃罗尔·弗林了，而且因为阿尔弗雷德是个非常严肃的人，不是吗？阿尔弗雷德身上并没有多少幽默感，我觉得这样说很公允。我们刚才——你说了，他满脑子都在思考上帝和他的臣民。
And infiltrates theiking camp and learns all their secrets he gigs and they love it and they all kind of gather around and listen to his latest hits and he picks up all the information that absolutely definitely happened tom in fact that story when i wrote my kids book i um i have to confess i left that story out oh why it just seemed so implausible i mean it seemed it's... It's so Walter Scott, isn't it? So would you believe, I put in the cakes, I even put in some Cuthbert, but I thought I'd draw a line at the infiltrating,
所以这种——“我知道我要怎么做了”——非常像埃罗尔·弗林，是的，而且毫无疑问，还会有一个撒克逊贵妇——完全正确，完全正确。这实际上有点像亨利八世，就是那种感觉。确实有那么一点，呃，不过而且，这也是一种——我的意思是，这太像那种劣质的中世纪传奇了，不是吗？确实如此。但有一件事确实发生了——而且我认为这绝对是真实的，是同时代的人所描述的——那就是当阿尔弗雷德在阿瑟尔尼（Athelny）筹划下一步行动时，第二支维京军队入侵了韦塞克斯。这支军队从威尔士穿过来，入侵了德文郡（Devon），由我们的老朋友胡巴（Hubba）率领。是的，呃，他是无骨者伊瓦尔（Ivar the Boneless）的兄弟，也就是传说中朗纳尔·洛德布罗克（Ragnar Lothbrok）的儿子之一，托马斯，如果你相信传说的话。是的，他带着一面渡鸦战旗——也就是奥丁的象征——这一切都极其可怕。你知道的，当你闲逛在埃克斯穆尔（Exmoor）、迈因黑德（Minehead）或波洛克（Porlock）或者其他什么地方时，突然看到这些人逼近……
the Vikings dressed as a minstrel. I also just thought it set the wrong... Because I was going for a very Churchillian kind of tone. Dressing up as a minstrel is just too Faye, isn't it? It's too Errol Flynn. Yeah, the busking is much too errol flynn and because alfred is very serious isn't it there's not much humor with alfred i think it's fair to say what we just you said he's thinking he spends all this time thinking about god and his people
但他们被萨默塞特的长老（ealderman）给逼入了绝境——他的名字几乎和胡巴一样好听，他的名字叫奥德（Odder）。是的，这就是胡巴对阵奥德，而奥德击败了胡巴，缴获了渡鸦战旗。我的意思是，用托尔金的话来说，这有点像圣盔谷之战（Helm's Deep），对吧？哦，这可是件了不得的大事，托马斯。那是一个……因为渡鸦战旗……
so this sort of i know what i'll do it's very errol flynn yes yeah and doubtless there's some saxon lady who exactly exactly it's actually to henry the eighth that's what it is yeah there is a bit of that uh but and also it's too i mean it's too kind of cod medieval isn't it it is but something that does happen and this i think is absolutely authentic it's it's described by contemporaries is that while alfred is on athelny plotting what to do there is a second viking army invades wessex and this crosses from wales um invades devon and it is led by our old friend hubba yeah uh who is the brother of iva the boneless one of the sons of ragnar lothbrok tom if you believe the legends yes and he's he's carrying a raven banner so the raven the emblem of odin and it's all terrifying you know you're kind of
赶走萨鲁曼。在这类故事的传奇版本中，渡鸦战旗某种程度上是维京人战无不胜的象征。我想这种说法是：它是朗纳尔·洛德布罗克的遗孀织造的，并交给她的儿子们，让他们在寻求复仇时带到英格兰。而且，你知道的，只要渡鸦战旗还在飘扬，他们就永远不会被盎格鲁-撒克逊人击败。所以当撒克逊人——但现在它没了。
hanging out on exmoor or something minehead or porlock or whatever and suddenly you see these guys approaching um but they are cornered by the uh the elder men of somerset um who has a name almost as good as hubba and his name is odder yeah it's hubba against odder and odder defeats hubba captures the raven banner And I mean, that's in Tolkien terms, that's kind of Helm's Deep, isn't it? Oh, this is a massively big deal, Tom. That's a... Because the Raven banner...
没错。当然，此时更具怀疑精神的听众会说：“他们已经聊了12分钟了，他们说的话没有一句是真的。”好吧，我认为这场胜利确实存在，不是吗？奥德确实取得了他的胜利。是的。
Get rid of Saruman. In the sort of legendary versions of this story, the Raven banner is the sort of badge of the Vikings' invincibility. And I think the claim is that it was woven by Ragnar Lothbrok's widow and given to her sons to carry to England when they sought revenge. And that, you know, as long as the Raven banner flew, they would never be defeated by the Anglo-Saxons. So when the Saxons... But now it's gone.
想想罗马人对他们的军旗是多么的重视。是的。也许他们确实缴获了某种旗帜，而这成为了一个巨大的徽记、对他们巨大的鼓舞和极大的提振。正是在这个时候，不是吗？阿尔弗雷德派人四处传信，说道：“告诉所有人我还活着。”让我们就在这个时候——不是吗？——阿尔弗雷德派人四处传信，说道：“告诉所有人我还活着。让我们行动起来。”
Exactly. Now, of course, more sceptical listeners at this point will be saying, they've been talking for 12 minutes, nothing they've said is true. Well, I think there is this victory, isn't there? Odder does get his victory. Yeah.
你知道的，非常类似——你开启了第一集，不是吗，托马斯？是的，令人激动的片段。埃格伯特之石（Egbert's Stone）的会面。埃格伯特之石。我的意思是，这非常J·R·R·托尔金。而且没有理由怀疑他们没有在埃格伯特之石会面。好吧，这绝对是标准做法。如果你想组建军队、召集国民军（fyrd）、征集兵丁，就有一些特定的地点可以汇合。
Think how seriously the Romans taught their standards. Yeah. Maybe they do capture some kind of banner, and this is a tremendous badge and a great fillip to them and a great boost. And it's at this point, isn't it, that Alfred sends messages out and says, tell everybody I'm still alive. Let's at this point, isn't it, that Alfred sends messages out and says, tell everybody I'm still alive. Let's do this.
而且，在一个由他的祖父——那位将韦塞克斯塑造成强大帝国的伟大国王——所设立的石头旁会面，这绝对是再合适不过了。所以，是的，我认为这一切完全可信。他发出了召集令，而且应召者云集。是的，乔治——你知道一个伟大的作家是如何描述这个场景的吗，托马斯？是的，给我们讲讲吧。于是阿尔弗雷德骑马越过山丘，在他脚下，铺展在草甸上的是：他可以看到人们纷纷站起身来，成百上千的人——不是身经百战的勇士，而是普通的农民和村民，响应他们领袖的召唤聚集在一起。
You know, very sort of, you opened the first episode, didn't you, Tom? Yes, stirring passage. The meeting at Egbert's Stone. Egbert's Stone. I mean, it's very JRR Tolkien. And there's no reason to doubt that they did meet at Egbert's Stone. Well, this is absolutely standard practice. If you want to raise the army, raise the fyrd, raise your levies, there are certain places that you meet.
我对后者的真实性持怀疑态度。好吧，你又没写这本书，所以你怎么想并不重要。好吧，你知道的，阿尔弗雷德的军队里全都是极其精锐的战士，而这的证明就是他们赢了。是的，就是这样。在埃格伯特之石会面两天后，他们在埃丁顿（Eddington）村外追上了丹麦人。你去过埃丁顿吗，托马斯？目前还不完全清楚埃丁顿究竟在什么地方，但我去过传统上认为可能发生过这场战役的各个地点。是的。哦，那太好了。我就知道你会这样。你知道阿瑟主教（Bishop Asser）是怎么说的吗？
And the idea that you would meet at a stone set up by his grandfather, the great king who'd made Wessex, the power that it was, absolutely fitting. So, yes, I think all that is entirely credible. And he gives out the summonsons and the summons is answered yeah not george you know what a great writer says about this scene tom yeah tell us so alfred rides over the uh hill and below him spread across the meadows he could see people rising to their feet hundreds thousands of people not warriors not, but ordinary farmers and villagers gathered in answer to their captain's call.
阿尔弗雷德像一头野猪一样大喊大叫，挥舞着圣经，丹麦人就像春天的积雪一样融化了。阿尔弗雷德以密集的阵型进行凶猛的战斗，攻击了整个异教徒军队，这就是为什么我认为——你知道的——这些仅仅是卑微农夫的说法是不可信的。我认为这绝对是震撼人心的，他们坚定不移地坚持了很长一段时间，以至于在上帝的意志下，他最终取得了胜利。他在他们中间大开杀戒，并将他们一路追击到他们的堡垒，将其砍倒在地。他们的堡垒就是奇本汉（Chippenham），当初正是从那里把阿尔弗雷德赶入夜色的。他们把自己 barricade（ barricaded）在里面，不是吗？两个星期里，阿尔弗雷德对他们围城，最终他们屈服了。
I'm less convinced by that. Well, you haven't written the book, so it doesn't matter what you think. Well, you know, Alfred's army is full of very proficient fighters, and the measure of that is that they win. Yeah. Well, this is the thing. Two days after the meeting at Egbertstone, they catch up with the Danes outside the village of Eddington. Have you been to Eddington, Tom? It's not entirely clear where Eddington is, but I have been to all the various locations where it is traditionally thought it might have been fought. Yes. Oh, that's good. I would expect nothing less. You know what Bishop Asser says
他们达成了条款。古斯伦（Guthrum）不仅同意离开，还同意接受洗礼，成为阿尔弗雷德的教子。你知道他取的名字是什么吗？我知道。你当然知道。埃塞尔斯坦（Athelstan）。埃塞尔斯坦。让我们来谈谈这个，因为对某些人来说，这似乎是——
about it? Alfred shouted like a boar and waved a bible and the danes melted away like snow in spring kind of alfred attacked the whole pagan army fighting ferociously in dense order which is why i think it's improbable that you know these are just humble farmhands i think this is absolutely shocking and persevered resolutely for a long time to let lengthen by god's will he won the victory he made great slaughter among them and pursued them to their fortress, hacking them down. And their fortress is Chippenham, where they sent Alfred running into the night. And they barricade themselves inside, don't they? For a fortnight, Alfred puts them under siege and they give in.
在经历了这些各种各样的激动人心的传说之后——烤饼、圣卡斯伯特、乔装成吟游诗人、在石头旁会面、普通的农民和村民，托马斯。是的，韦塞克斯的普通儿女。响应他们领袖的召唤。在经历了这一切之后，他击败了古斯伦。乌拉，乌拉。巨大的胜利。多么伟大的转折点。然后他与古斯伦达成了一项协议，在协议中，古斯伦接受了洗礼，并实际上被派去作为一名基督教国王去担任东盎格利亚的国王。所以，这现在让我们非常深切地回到了现实主义历史的世界，不是吗？而不是传说。回到了现实政治（realpolitik）的世界。因为阿尔弗雷德知道，维京人实际上不可能仅仅被击败并赶回大海。他们太强大了，做不到这一点。
And they arrive at terms. And Guthrum agrees to not only go away, but to be baptized and to become Alfred's godson. And you know the name that he takes? I do. Of course you do. Athelstan. Athelstan. So let's talk about this, because this is a sort of, to some people, it might seem that
他必须与古斯伦达成协议。而且我认为，他们双方都从这笔交易中获益了。所以阿尔弗雷德赢得了胜利，同时他现在也有了一个基督教邻居。而且阿尔弗雷德是他的教父，对吧？阿尔弗雷德赞助了这场洗礼。是的，所以他在一个叫阿勒（Aller）的地方接受了洗礼，不是穆斯林的那个真主安拉（Allah），而是 A-double-L-E-R，那是离阿瑟尔尼最近的教堂。所以非常有可能是阿尔弗雷德在阿瑟尔尼期间去祈祷的地方。因此它具有巨大的象征意义。古斯伦的一些勇士也接受了洗礼，不是吗？他最亲密的伙伴。他们穿着白袍作为纯洁的象征。他们基本上承认了阿尔弗雷德是他们的——是什么？作为他们的宗主吗？不太算。
after these various sort of stirring legends, the Cakes, St. Cuthbert, impersonating a minstrel, meeting at the Stone, ordinary farmers and villagers, Tom. Yeah, the ordinary sons of Wessex. To answer their captain's call. After all this, he beats Guthrum. Hurrah, hurrah. Tremendous victory. What a great turning point. And then he does a deal with Guthrum, in which Guthrum is baptised and is actually sent off to become king of East Anglia as a Christian king. So this now returns us very much to the world of realistic history, doesn't it? Rather than legend. Of realpolitik. That Alfred knows the Vikings actually can't just be defeated and driven back into the sea. They're much too powerful for that.
嗯，他们是在承认阿尔弗雷德所代表的王权模式是值得拥有的东西。因此，他们从对盎格鲁-撒克逊王权能提供给他们的纯粹掠夺性的理解，转变为认识到他们也可以从中分得一杯羹。所以我认为这是一种承认：阿尔弗雷德拥有植根于超自然维度以及他世俗地位的权威储备。而且维京人也愿意承认这一点。可能是失去（战旗）导致古斯伦接受了这样的现实：这位基督教国王确实像盎格鲁-撒克逊人所说的那样强大，在这种情况下，他想成为其中一部分。我认为这是最可能的解释，因为从这一刻起，古斯伦基本上就安分守己了。他确实如此，不是吗？
He has to do a deal with Guthrum. And they both win from this deal, I would say. So Alfred has his victory, and he also now has a Christian neighbour. And Alfred is his godfather, that's right, isn't it? Alfred has sponsored the baptism. Yeah, so he gets baptised at a place called Allah, not as in the Muslim god, but A-double-L-E-R, which is the church that was closest to Athelni. And so it's very possible that that was where Alfred was going to pray
在某种程度上，这实际上是维京人更普遍命运的预演。成为基督徒代表着地位的提升，在声望上也是如此，不是吗？嗯，我在几十年后的东盎格利亚铸造了一枚极其珍贵的硬币。所以它上面盖有阿尔弗雷德的儿子爱德华（Edward）的名字，但这是一枚赝品，而且它被一个维京朝圣者带到了罗马。所以这表明的首先是，你知道的，维京人去了罗马，他们显然是基督徒；但这也是因为他们想要——你知道的——他们对盎格鲁-撒克逊财富的根源有了足够的理解，以至于他们也想拥有铸币。
during his time on Athelni. So it has a great symbolic resonance. And some of Guthrum's warriors are baptized too, aren't they? His closest kind of companions. They wear these white robes as symbols of their purity. And they are basically acknowledging Alfred as their, as what? As their overlord? Not quite.
并且他们正在买进这种——你知道的——整个体制。所以我想这就是正在发生的事情。此外还有一种可能性，一些历史学家对此进行了沉思，我显然——而且我相信你也是——甚至都不愿意去细想，但我或许应该提一下，那就是我们对这一时期所有事情的理解在很大程度上都依赖于阿尔弗雷德及其赞助。而且有可能，关于他彻底拜倒、面临彻底湮灭、随后迎来惊人卷土重来的叙事，或许已经被
Well, they are acknowledging the model of kingship that Alfred represents as being something worth having. So they've moved from a purely predatory understanding of what the Anglo-Saxon kingships could offer them to a recognition that they could have a part of it. So I think it's an acknowledgement that Alfred has reserves of authority that are rooted in the dimension of the supernatural, as well as in his earthly status. And that this is something that the Vikings are willing to acknowledge. And it may be that the loss of have led Guthrum to accept that the Christian king is actually as powerful as the Anglo-Saxons have said, in which case he wants to be a part of it. And that is the likeliest explanation, I think, because from this point on, Guthrum basically behaves himself. He does, doesn't he?
稍微修饰过了，或许事情对阿尔弗雷德来说并不像史料所描绘的那样糟糕。因此，当古斯伦同意接受洗礼时，这并不像是一场突如其来的惨败带来的巨大冲击，而是一种认识：实际上，阿尔弗雷德和韦塞克斯君主国并不像其他君主国那样容易被根除。我的意思是，这是一种可能性。我们显然不能——不，我们不能，因为那会把过去40分钟的播客变成一个笑话。不，我不这么认为。我的意思是，你或许可以对那种说法稍微泼一点冷水。是的。
And in some ways, this is actually a preview of what will happen to the Vikings more generally. That becoming Christian represents a step up in status doesn't it in prestige well i have this incredible coin minted um in east anglia a few a few decades later so it's it's stamped with the name of alfred's son edward but it's a fake uh and it's been taken by a viking pilgrim to rome and say what that is showing is firstly that, you know, Vikings are going to Rome, they're obviously Christian, but it's also the fact that they want the, you know, they've come to a sufficient understanding of the roots of Anglo-Saxon wealth that they want to have coinage to.
稍微泼一点，或许吧。但是，你知道的，这些史料是在那些经历过这些事件的人仍然活着的时候写出来的，所以他们不可能凭空捏造。但也许里面加入了一点点包装。是的。谁知道呢？我喜欢与古斯伦达成的这笔交易，
And they're buying into the kind of, you know, the whole system. So I think that that's what's going on. There is also one further possibility that some historians brood, which I obviously, and I'm sure you as well, don't even want to contemplate, but I should probably mention it, which is that our understanding of everything to do with this period is pretty much dependent on Alfred and his sponsorship. And it's possible that the narrative of his utter prostration, the utter oblivion that he faced, and then this spectacular comeback, that perhaps it's been
因为我认为它把我们带回了那些感觉具体、感觉真实的领域。阿尔弗雷德放眼望去——你知道的，当他从韦塞克斯眺望时，他看到——你知道的，维京人并不会就此——所有这成千上万的人并不会就此凭空消失。他必须设法与他们达成某种权宜之计（modus vivendi）。他或许可以在长远上将他们逼退、侵蚀他们的边界、收复失地。但就目前而言，如果他在古斯伦那里拥有一个顺从的邻居，这对韦塞克斯来说就再好不过了。嗯，还有，我的意思是，条约的签署需要时间。因此，直到 886 年，基本上对麦西亚的划分——也就是从伦敦一直延伸到默西河（Mersey）的一条分界线——才通过条约确立下来。
slightly shaped, and that perhaps things weren't quite as bad for Alfred as the sources make out. And that therefore, when Guthrum agrees to be baptized, it's not like it's just the sudden shock of an abrupt defeat, but a kind of recognition that actually Alfred and the Wessexian monarchy cannot be extirpated as easily as the other monarchies have been. I mean, that is a possibility. We obviously cannot. No, we can't because that would make a mockery of about the last 40 minutes of podcasting. No, I don't think so. I mean, you could a little bit of shade perhaps on that. Yeah.
它建立了这样几个王国：一边是讲英语的、受英国法律统治的人，另一边是丹麦人、受丹麦法律管辖的人。因此，在适当的时候，这就演变成了“丹麦法区”（Danelaw）这个短语。它与阿尔弗雷德并非同时代。对于那些对此不熟悉的人来说，如果你在今天的 2022 年在英格兰画一条对角线，你通常会发现地名，或者实际上甚至是带有丹麦-诺斯语尾缀的姓氏，比如-thorpe、-thwaites 等等，它们都位于远端，位于这条分界线的东北部那一侧。
A little bit, perhaps. But, you know, these sources are being written when people who've lived through these events were alive, so they couldn't just make it up from scratch. But perhaps there's been a little bit of spin. Yeah. Who knows? I like the deal with Guthrum
而那笔交易在英格兰性（Englishness）、英国文化、你知道的，英语语言等等的历史中被证明具有极其重要的意义。我的意思是，这可以追溯到你刚才所说的，托马斯，关于偶然性（contingency）。你知道的，我们在本播客中经常谈论的事情——结构性变化与偶然性，是的——这赋予了韦塞克斯一种它此前从未有过的稳定程度，这在阿尔弗雷德统治下当然是如此，在他的兄弟们统治时期也绝非如此，而且这种稳定很久未曾有了。而这的证明是，撤退的不仅仅是古斯伦，在 879 年，另一支在 878 年出现在泰晤士河口的维京军队——也就是阿尔弗雷德赢得伟大胜利的同一年——
because I think it returns us to the realm of what feels concrete and what feels realistic. Alfred looks out, you know, as he looks out from Wessex, he sees that, you know, the Vikings are not just going to all these thousands of people are not just going to vanish. That he has to find a modus vivendi for the time being with them. And he can, you know, he can perhaps in the long run, push them back, erode their boundaries, retake land. But for the time being, if he has a compliant neighbour in Guthrum, so much the better for Wessex. Well, also, I mean, it takes time for the treaty to be signed. So it's not until 886 that the division of basically of Mercia, so a line running from London up to the Mersey becomes instituted by treaty.
他们扬帆起航了。他们觉得这不值得。让我们去欧洲大陆掠夺法兰克人吧。他们将离开——我想是 13 年，13 年的时间，而这 12 到 13 年基本上使阿尔弗雷德能够投身于恢复其王国的伟大事业中。我认为正是这项事业真正证明了他作为——你知道的——一位伟大国王的价值，一位因其成就规模而值得被铭记的国王。完美，那么让我们休息一下，托马斯，去喝点蜂蜜酒或者别的什么。
And it sets up for kingdoms with English on one side ruled by English laws and Danes on the other governed by Danish laws. And so that in due course is where the phrase the Dane law. It's not contemporary with Alfred. And for people who are not familiar with this, so if you draw a diagonal line across England today in 2022, you will generally find that place names, or indeed surnames actually, with Danish Norse endings, so Thorpe, Thwaites, and so on, they're all on the far side, on the sort of the northeastern
吃点鱼。是的。然后我们在中场休息后回来，你可以为阿尔弗雷德不朽的伟大进行论证。我想你要谈论的是——听到这话我很难过——我想你要谈论的是城市规划。但我想你也会谈论一些更有趣的事情。所以城市规划真的非常非常有趣。如果你热爱城市规划，你就在天堂里了；如果你不热爱它，别担心，还有大量其他有趣的东西，所以中场休息后再见。
side of that dividing line. And that deal was to prove massively important in the history of Englishness, English culture, you know, the English language, all these kinds of things. I mean, this goes back to what you were saying, Tom, about contingency. You know, the thing we talk about so often in this podcast the structural changes versus contingencies yes and this gives wessex a degree of stability that it has not had certainly under alfred certainly not under his brothers not for a very long time and the measure of this is that it's not just guthrum who withdraws, but in 879, this other kind of Viking force that had appeared in the Thames estuary in 878, so the same year that Alfred is winning his great victory,
好吧，我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一丝秀场八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告的音频、加更节目和抢先购买现场门票的权限，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。托马斯和我正在讨论大王阿尔弗雷德的一生，以及他对抗维京人的伟大斗争。所以，托马斯，在上半场中，阿尔弗雷德击退了古斯伦，但打发他带着一个新名字去了东盎格利亚，而你接下来要为阿尔弗雷德作为伟大的城市规划师进行论证，所以请开始吧。
they set sail. They think this isn't worth it. Let's go off to the continent and plunder the Franks. And they will be away for, I think it's 13 years, 13 years and basically those 12 and 13 years enable alfred to set to the great labor of restoring his kingdom and it's that labor i think that really justifies the sense of him as you know as as a great king a king who who deserves to be remembered for for the scale of his achievements perfect so let's take a, Tom, to go and drink some mead or whatever. And eat some fish. Yeah. And then we'll return after the break
好吧，我正在论证阿尔弗雷德——正如我们在第一集里所谈到的——他作为战争统帅是伟大的，但有许多盎格鲁-撒克逊国王都做到了这一点。阿尔弗雷德的卓越之处在于他如何善用他在战争中的胜利。他似乎对如何修复和重建一个伤痕累累、流血漂橹的王国有着深刻的理解。他以一种强硬的方式做到这一点，他是一位强硬的统治者，就像哈罗德一样，你知道的，他——他没有哈罗德那么强硬，我觉得这样说很公允。他不是一个软柿子，他把他的臣民逼得非常非常紧，因为他认识到，有那么多的破坏，那么多的毁灭降临到英格兰，尤其是韦塞克斯，以至于重建的工作需要巨大巨大的努力。他愿意亲力亲为（put his shoulders to the wheel），但他也要求他的臣民同样这么做。没错。是的。你谈到了城市规划。基本上，他认识到，如果没有强大的坚固据点，没有能够产生金钱的市场，他就无法阻挡维京人。因为归根结底，金钱是战争的筋骨。黄金是战争的筋骨。黄金是战争的筋骨。
and you can make your case for Alfred's lasting greatness. I think you're going to be talking, it grieves me to say this, I think you're going to be talking about town planning. But I think you're also going to be talking about more interesting things. So town planning is really, really interesting. If you love town love town planning you're in clover if you don't love
因此，他刻意着手恢复或修复被废弃的罗马城镇，其中最著名的例子就是伦敦。所以我们讨论过——呃——他是如何掌控伦敦的，他在 886 年从维京人或麦西亚人手中夺取了伦敦的控制权，我们并不完全确定——他对其进行了加固，清除了瓦砾、杂草和野荨麻，并规划了街道。他在南部英格兰的其他地方也这样做了。但他还从零开始规划了许多定居点，并建造了巨大的防御工事。这方面的证明是，我不知道你有没有去过多塞特郡的韦勒姆（Wareham）。我从未去过韦勒姆，托马斯。那里的防御工事太棒了。那里的防御工事是如此之高，以至于在 1940 年，它们被用作防御德军海上登陆计划的一部分。所以你在那里能对阿尔弗雷德宏伟愿景的规模获得一种非常非常深刻的感受。据估计，韦塞克斯大约 5% 的全境人口都参与了这些——天哪——这些被称为“伯尔”（burh）的巨大结构的建设。
it don't worry there's loads of other fun stuff too so see you after the break all right i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our q a we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Tom and i are talking about the life of alfred the great
这就是“自治市”（borough）词源的由来。所以我们讨论过圣埃德蒙兹伯里（Bury St Edmunds），那是——你知道的——无论你在哪里看到“burh”，这基本上就是西撒克逊城市建设者的指导之手。所以这些——我的意思是，只要看看这份名单：埃克塞特（Exeter）、沙茨伯里（Shaftesbury）、巴斯（Bath）、威尔顿（Wilton）、牛津（Oxford）、沃灵福德（Wallingford）、白金汉（Buckingham）、沃里克（Warwick）——这些都是现在在当时的韦塞克斯和南部麦西亚非常熟悉的城镇。这是一种网络，不是吗？正如你所说的，坚固的据点。而且重点是，正如你所说，这不是一个你可以用一堵边界墙就能挡住袭击小队的时代。他们还是会来。但阿尔弗雷德的天才之处在于他说：好吧，如果他们要来，那就让他们来。如果我们建造了这些坚固的城镇，每个人都可以涌入城镇寻求庇护，而维京人在——他们极不擅长——他们其实并不怎么会攻城，因为他们没有攻城器械，他们没有所有的装备，他们也没有耐心。
and his great struggles against the vikings so tom in the first half alfred swore off guthrum but sent him packing to east anglia with a new name and you're about to make the case for alfred as the great town planner so crack on well i'm making the case for alfred as we talked about in the first episode that he is great as a a captain in war but there were many anglo-saxon kings who did that alfred is exceptional for the uses that he puts his victories in war too he seems to have an understanding of what it takes to repair and restore a badly maimed and bleeding kingdom and he he does this in a hard way he is a hard ruler like harold he's you know he's he's not quite as hard as harold i think it's fair to say
他们没有所有的装备。他们没有耐心。是的。这就是我们应对维京人威胁的方式。你知道的，他们可以攻击拥有所有黄金的奇本汉或修道院，因为那里相对缺乏防御。
he's not he's not a soft touch and he pushes his subjects very very hard because he recognizes that there has been so much destruction so much ruin ruin visited on England and on Wessex in particular, that the labour of restoration demands huge, huge effort. And he's willing to put his shoulders to the wheel, but he demands that his subjects do as well. Right. Yeah. And you talked about town planning. Basically, he recognizes that he cannot stop the Vikings without strong fortified centers and without markets that are generating money. Because ultimately, money is the sinews of war. Gold is the sinew of war gold is the sinew of war so he consciously sets out either to restore or repair abandoned roman towns of which the most famous example is london so we we talked um about how he gets hold of london he takes possession of london in 886 either from the vikings or from
但是，如果赚钱的设施——即集市——以及由此筹集的黄金和修道院都处于防御工事之内，那么想要夺取它们就会变得难上加难。我想我提到过，我让阿尔弗雷德的女儿埃塞尔弗莱德（Athelflad）在切斯特（Chester）为我铸造了这枚硬币，它展示了这座塔，而这座塔同时也是教会的象征。所以它是关于将上帝的律法恢复到饱受异教徒蹂躏的土地上。但它也是军事力量的象征。它是一个壁垒。正是这种理念——本质上，金钱的产生、修道院的修复、防御工事的建造，所有这些都是交织在一起的项目。
the mercians we're not entirely sure um and he fortifies it and he clears it of rubble and weeds and singing nettles and lays out street plans. And he does this elsewhere as well across southern England. But he also plants a lot of settlements from scratch and he builds huge fortifications. And the measure of that is, I don't know if you've been to Wareham in Dorset. I've never been to Wareham, Tom. It's fantastic. The fortifications are so high that they used them in 1940 as they were going to be used as part of the defences against the seaborne German landing. So you get a really, really impressive sense of the scale of Alfred's vision there. And it's been estimated that something like maybe 5 percent of the entire population
阿尔弗雷德基本上是英格兰城市化之父，所以迈克尔·伍德（Michael Wood）——你知道的，他关于这一时期的著作是如此精妙——他称赞这是盎格鲁-撒克逊国家最卓越的单项成就。有一本绝对精彩的书涵盖了这一点，由约翰·布莱尔（John Blair）所著的《建造盎格鲁-撒克逊英格兰》（Building Anglo-Saxon England），非常美妙。读到这些内容令人惊叹。这简直就是国家建设。是的，它是。我的意思是，这几乎——你知道的——某种你可能更容易联想到法老时代的埃及或类似地方的事情。
of wessex were involved in the construction of these crikey these enormous structures which are called burrs so that's where you get borough so we talked about berry st edmunds that's you know yeah wherever you have a burr that's basically the guiding hand of a west saxon town builder so these are i mean just looking at the list exeter shaftsbury bath wilton oxford wallingford buckingham warwick these are towns that are now very familiar across what would have then been um wessex and southern mercia it's this sort of network isn't it as you said of strongholds and the point is as you said you know this isn't an age when you can stop you where you can just stop a raiding party day with a kind of border wall they're gonna come but alfred's genius is he says well let well you know if they come they come if we've built these
这是一个宏大的国家基础设施建设项目。不仅如此，我的意思是，就——你需要一个官僚机构来完成它。所以你需要一定程度的识字率，因为你需要安排这一切。而且他安排的一部分是，每年大约有 25,000 多人基本上被征召入伍，对吧？他们基本上轮流在所有这些伯尔的城墙上站岗，守卫城墙。而这同样需要一种早期中世纪欧洲国家中罕见的行政肌肉。确实如此。
fortified towns and everybody can just pile into the town take shelter and the vikings are terrible at they don't really do sieges because they don't have siege engines they don't have all the equipment they don't have patience for it They don't have all the equipment. They don't have the patience for it. Yeah. This is how we deal with the Viking threat. You know, and they can attack Chippenham where all the gold is or the monasteries because they're relatively undefended.
所以，这就是阿尔弗雷德的另一个伟大痴迷——对学习复兴的痴迷——发挥作用的地方。因为如果没有抄写员，你就无法拥有那种级别的官僚控制。没有学习，你就无法拥有抄写员。在阿尔弗雷德看来，没有修道院和女修道院，你就无法拥有学习。他对此承诺的证明是他自己每天都要花数小时进行学习。他非常感人地描述了这一点。他翻译了一篇由格里高利大帝（Gregory the Great）撰写的文本，这位伟大的教皇曾派遣传教士前往英格兰，因此始终备受盎格鲁人和撒克逊人的最高敬意。阿尔弗雷德在翻译这篇文本的引言中写道：
But if the money-making facilities, namely marketplaces, and then the gold that is raised from that and the monasteries are within fortifications, then it becomes much, much harder to get hold of it. I think I mentioned, I got this coin minted by Athelflad, Alfred's daughter in Chester, and it shows this tower and the tower is simultaneously an emblem of the church. So it's about the restoration of God's writ to land savaged by heathens. But it's also an emblem of military strength. It's a bulwark. And it's that kind of idea that essentially the generation of money, the repairing of monasteries, the construction of fortifications, these are all kind of interwoven projects.
“我回想起在一切遭受洗劫和焚烧之前，英格兰各地的教堂里到处都是宝藏和书籍。”一切都遭受了洗劫和焚烧，而这正是他试图恢复的。他试图恢复宝藏，他试图恢复书籍。他使他的宫廷成为来自欧洲大陆、法兰克土地以及麦西亚的学者们的伟大学习中心。麦西亚似乎在维京人的袭击中幸存得更好一些，也许是因为他们更早地达成了妥协。
And Alfred basically is the father of english urbanism and so michael wood you know who who writes so brilliantly on this period yeah he's he's hailed it as probably the most remarkable single achievement of the anglo-saxon state and there's an absolutely brilliant book that covers this it's wonderful by uh by john blair building anglo-saxonon England. And it's amazing to read about it. It's literally state building. Yeah, it is. I mean, it's almost, you know, kind of the kind of thing that you might more readily associate with pharaonic Egypt or something.
这充分说明了阿尔弗雷德是麦西亚学术的一位伟大赞助者。其中最杰出的人物是一个名叫普拉加蒙德（Plagamund）的人，他后来成为了坎特伯雷大主教。普拉加蒙德。普拉加蒙德。我也有他的一枚硬币。真的吗？
It's a vast national project of infrastructure building. Well, not just that, but I mean, in terms of, you need a bureaucracy to do it. So you need a degree of literacy because you need to arrange all this and he also part of the arrangement is every year i think just over 25 000 men are basically they're basically conscripted aren't they to take their turn on the walls of all these burrs guarding the walls and again that requires a level of administrative muscle that you don't get in most early medieval European states. It does.
这是一个浩大的国家基础设施建设项目。嗯，不仅如此，我的意思是，从你需要官僚体制来完成它的角度来看。所以你需要一定程度的识字率，因为你需要安排这一切，而且他安排的一部分是，每年我想要么稍微多一点25,000名男子，他们基本上被征召入伍了，不是吗？去轮流驻守所有这些堡垒的城墙，保卫城墙，这同样需要大多数早期中世纪欧洲国家所不具备的行政管理能力。确实如此。
And so this is where Alfred's other great obsession, which is with the restoration of learning, comes in. Because you cannot have that kind of level of bureaucratic control without scribes. You can't have scribes without learning. You can't have learning, as Alfred sees it, without monasteries and nunneries. And the measure of his commitment to this is that he himself devotes hours of his day to learning. And he describes this very movingly. He does a translation of a text written by Gregory the Great, the great pope who had
这就是阿尔弗雷德的另一个伟大执念——恢复学术——发挥作用的地方。因为没有抄写员，你就无法拥有那种级别的官僚控制。没有学习，你就无法拥有抄写员。正如阿尔弗雷德所见，没有修道院和女修道院，你就无法拥有学习。他对此投入的决心的衡量标准是，他自己每天都要花数小时来学习。他非常感人地描述了这一点。他翻译了一篇由格里高利大帝（Great Pope）撰写的文本，这位伟大的教皇曾
sent the missionaries to England and who therefore is always regarded with the utmost respect by the Angles and the Saxons. And Alfred writes in his introduction to his translation of this, he says, I recollected how before everything was ransacked and burned, the churches throughout England stood filled with treasures and books. And it's everything was ransacked and burned and that's what he's trying to bring back he's trying to restore treasure and he's trying to restore books and he makes his court a great center of learning for scholars from the continent from the frankish lands but also from mercia and mercia seems to have survived um the viking raids better perhaps because they arrived at accommodation earlier.
派遣传教士前往英格兰，因此一直受到盎格鲁人和撒克逊人的无比尊敬。阿尔弗雷德在自己翻译这篇文本的序言中写道，他回忆起在一切都被洗劫和焚烧之前，英格兰各地的教堂里都塞满了珍宝和书籍。这就是一切被洗劫和焚烧的情形，这也是他试图恢复的，他试图恢复珍宝，他试图恢复书籍，他把他的宫殿打造成了一个伟大的学术中心，吸引了来自欧洲大陆、法兰克土地以及麦西亚的学者，而且麦西亚似乎更好地挺住了维京人的袭击，也许是因为他们更早地达成了妥协。
And it's really telling that Alfred is a great, great patron of Mercia learning. And the most distinguished figure is a guy called Plagamund who becomes Archbishop of Canterbury. Plagamund. Plagamund. I've got one of his coins as well. Have you?
非常说明问题的是，阿尔弗雷德是麦西亚学术的伟大赞助人。最杰出的人物是一个叫普拉加蒙德（Plagamund）的人，他后来成为了坎特伯雷大主教。普拉加蒙德。普拉加蒙德。我也有他的一枚硬币。是吗？
He's got coins of them all. I've got them all in 890. And this sense that the learning of mercia is part of the common inheritance that the west saxons share with everybody in what will come to be called england is crucial not just for providing the kind of the bureaucracy that alfred needs but also much more kind of potently a sense of Anglo-Saxon identity. And what you're getting in the late 880s and 890s is Alfred is starting to issue charters in which he terms himself king of the Anglo-Saxons.
他有所有这些钱币。我在890年把它们全收齐了。这种认为麦西亚的学术是西撒克逊人与后来被称为英格兰的所有人共同传承的一部分的观念，不仅对于提供阿尔弗雷德所需的官僚体制至关重要，而且更强有力地赋予了人们一种盎格鲁-撒克逊身份认同。你在880年代末和890年代看到的，是阿尔弗雷德开始颁发宪章，在其中他称自己为盎格鲁-撒克逊人的国王。
So this is not a phrase that is invented by racists. This is a phrase that Alfred is using in his charters to describe this emergent sense that the Saxons and the Angles are, in a way, a common people. And one of the great projects that Alfred sponsors is a translation into English of Bede's Ecclesiastical History of the English People, which we talked about. Bede, the great Northumbrian scholar who wrote this incredible account of how the Angles and Saxons are given England by God and how they then are brought to Christ and their role as a Christian people. Alfred translates this and he sponsors the use in the vernacular of this word Anglekin.
所以这不是种族主义者发明的一个短语。这是阿尔弗雷德在他的宪章中用来描述这种新兴意识的短语，即撒克逊人和盎格鲁人在某种程度上是一个共同的民族。阿尔弗雷德赞助的伟大项目之一，就是将我们讨论过的贝德的《英格兰教会史》翻译成英文。贝德这位伟大的诺森比亚学者撰写了这篇令人难以置信的记载，讲述了上帝如何将英格兰赐予盎格鲁人和撒克逊人，他们又是如何归信基督的，以及他们作为基督教民族的角色。阿尔弗雷德翻译了这本书，并赞助在方言中使用“Anglekin”（盎格鲁族）这个词。
So this will become the English. When Aelswith, his Mercian wife, dies, she is described as the true and beloved lady of the English, Domina Anglorum. So that could be a reference to the Angles of Mercia, but it's not because she's also the Queen of the West Saxons. So there, Angli is being used to describe both Saxons and Mercians. And this is the great project of state building that Alfred sets in train that will be picked up by Edward, his son, who will conquer East Anglia and in due course take over Mercia. But not before Alfred's daughter, Athelflaed, who I mentioned, whose coin I bought. You may wonder what she's doing minting coins in Chester. She marries a
所以这将成为“English”（英格兰人/英语）。当他的麦西亚妻子埃尔斯维思去世时，她被描述为英格兰人真正挚爱的夫人，即“Domina Anglorum”。这可能是指麦西亚的盎格鲁人，但事实并非如此，因为她也是西撒克逊人的王后。因此，这里的“Angli”被用来同时指代撒克逊人和麦西亚人。这就是阿尔弗雷德开启的伟大的国家建设工程，这个工程后来由他的儿子爱德华接手，爱德华征服了东盎格利亚并在适当的时候接管了麦西亚。但在阿尔弗雷德的女儿埃塞尔弗莱德之前——我提到过她，我还买过她的硬币，你可能想知道她在切斯特铸造硬币做什么——她嫁给了一位
Mercian nobleman called Athelred, who has basically become Alfred's deputy in Mercia. He is Lord of the Mercians when he dies, Athelflad becomes Lady of the Mercians. And again, it's about this idea of the angles of Mercia, the Saxons of Wessex becoming a single people. And this is the great vision that is realized under athelstan who is alfred's grandson and none of this would have been possible without alfred's vision i think so he's building in england a new a new identity a new a more capacious identity that would include wessex mercia other english-speaking kingdoms christian kingdoms and it's based on administration based on the physical concrete stuff of the birds,
名叫埃塞尔雷德的麦西亚贵族，他基本上成了阿尔弗雷德在麦西亚的副手。他死时是麦西亚人的领主，埃塞尔弗莱德则成为了麦西亚人的女领主。再次，这关乎这样一种理念：麦西亚的盎格鲁人和威塞克斯的撒克逊人正在融为一个单一的民族。这就是阿尔弗雷德的孙子埃塞尔斯坦所实现的伟大愿景，我认为，如果没有阿尔弗雷德的远见，这一切都是不可能实现的。因此，他正在英格兰构建一种新的身份认同，一种新的、更具包容性的身份认同，它将包括威塞克斯、麦西亚、其他讲英语的王国以及基督教王国，并且它是建立在行政管理的基础上的，建立在伯尔(Burh)城堡这种实实在在的物质基础之上，
but it's also based on all these translated books, isn't it? Alfred, I mean, that's a wonderful line. He says at one point, very few people can understand Latin anymore because it's fallen into sort of disrepair. And he says, our forefathers loved wisdom and left it to us. Here we can still see their footprints, but we cannot follow them.
但它也建立在所有这些翻译书籍的基础上，不是吗？我的意思是，阿尔弗雷德说过一句非常精彩的话。他在某个时候说，极少有人还能理解拉丁语了，因为它已经荒废了。他说，我们的先辈热爱智慧，并将其留给了我们。在这里我们依然能看到他们的足迹，但我们却无法追随他们。
And therefore, we have lost both wealth and wisdom. And this idea that you translate all these great works into English, or as he puts it, what does he say? The language we can all understand. Yeah, so I think there are two sides to it. I think one is absolutely hard-nosed, very, very hard-nosed understanding of the reality of power yeah that money is incredibly important to alfred so an admirer of alfred commemorates him as the greatest treasure giver of all the kings i have ever heard of tell in recent times or any earthly king that
因此，我们既失去了财富，也失去了智慧。这种将所有这些伟大著作翻译成英语的想法，或者正如他所说的那样——他是怎么说的？——那种我们都能理解的语言。是的，所以我觉得这有两个方面。我认为其中一方面绝对是非常务实、极其务实地理解权力的现实，对的，金钱对阿尔弗雷德来说极其重要。因此，阿尔弗雷德的一位崇拜者赞颂他是他所听说过的所有国王中最伟大的财富施予者，无论是近代还是任何世俗君王，
i previously learned of um so alfred's renown as a kind of giver, a treasure giver, is fundamental to his prowess. The building of the Burrs are designed to provide a bulwark against Viking incursions, which do happen in the 890s. So that force that had come to the Thames estuary and gone off to the continent, they come back and they just batter themselves against the defenses of Wessex. There's a great battle where they're defeated by Æthelred, the Lord of the Mercians, in alliance with Alfred's son, Edward. Great victory. Alfred himself sees off a Viking siege at Exeter. And basically the Vikings give up. They recognize that there's no point and they withdraw and Wessex is fine. So the fact that Wessex has become
我以前了解过……因此，阿尔弗雷德作为一种施予者、财富施予者的声誉，是他的功绩的根本。伯尔城堡的建造旨在提供一道抵御维京人入侵的屏障，维京人的确在890年代再次入侵了。因此，那支曾来到泰晤士河口又前往欧洲大陆的力量卷土重来，他们只是在威塞克斯的防御工事前撞得头破血流。有一场大战，麦西亚领主埃塞尔雷德与阿尔弗雷德的儿子爱德华结盟，击败了他们。这是一场伟大的胜利。阿尔弗雷德本人在埃克塞特击退了一场维京人的围攻。基本上维京人放弃了。他们认识到毫无意义并撤退了，威塞克斯安然无恙。因此，威塞克斯之所以变得
militarily strong and has become wealthy, it's not an accident. It's absolutely conscious, deliberate policy on Alfred's part. And that is what makes him so remarkable a political figure. But I think he does also very, very devoutly believe that he is doing God's will because he is, you know, he describes kingship as a mighty burden. He has this responsibility before God. And I'm sure that that is what drives him to these incredible kind of extremes of effort and achievement. Well, in the first podcast, Tom, so on Monday, you talked about Alfred as a man who had this kind of inattention, didn't you? You said between being a sort of kindly Christian and also being a warlord. And what we do know about Alfred is that he's plagued by these mysterious internal, what appear to be kind of bowel complaints.
军事强大且富裕，并非偶然。这绝对是阿尔弗雷德有意识、故意的政策。正是这一点让他成为如此卓越的政治人物。但我认为他也非常、非常虔诚地相信自己在奉行上帝的意志，因为，你知道的，他将君主统治描述为一项沉重的负担。他在上帝面前负有这种责任。我确信，正是这一点驱使他付出了令人难以置信的巨大努力并取得了非凡的成就。好吧，在第一期播客里，汤姆，也就是在周一，你谈到阿尔弗雷德是一个有着这种注意力不集中特点的人，不是吗？你谈到了在做某种慈悲的基督徒和同时做军阀之间的一种状态。我们对阿尔弗雷德的了解是，他饱受这些神秘的内在困扰折磨，看起来像是某种肠道问题。
Some people say they might be piles. Well, so Asser, the Welsh bishop who writes his biography, he does say they're piles. And he has this, I think, possibly my favourite sentence in any biography I've ever written, where he says that the Lord God blessed Alfred with piles, with the gift of piles, because it's a cause of suffering. There's a claim that Alfred prayed for all this, because it would be good for him, rather like Thomas More with his hair shirt. This was Alfred's.
有人说可能是痔疮。好吧，撰写他传记的威尔士主教阿瑟确实说那是痔疮。他有这样一句话——我认为这可能是我读过的任何传记中最喜欢的一句——他说主上帝赐予阿尔弗雷德痔疮，作为痔疮的恩赐，因为这是痛苦的根源。有一种说法是阿尔弗雷德曾为此祈祷，因为这对他的修行有好处，有点像托马斯·莫尔穿着苦修衣。这就是阿尔弗雷德的苦修。
Alfred said, please torment me. And there's one biography of Alfred I read that suggested that this came on around the time of his wedding or something, that there was some sort of sexual explanation for all this. Have you seen this claim? Yeah. Do you believe it? I don't know. I mean, we you know oh you don't i don't know the details i don't think that we can get into the you know psychoanalysis of alfred and his wedding night or anything like that
阿尔弗雷德说：请折磨我吧。我读过的一本关于阿尔弗雷德的传记暗示，这大约发生在他的婚礼前后或其他什么时间，关于这一切似乎有一种某种性方面的解释。你见过这种说法吗？见过的。你相信吗？我不知道。我的意思是，我们……哦，你不知道，我不知道细节，我不认为我们可以去深入探讨阿尔弗雷德及其新婚之夜之类的心理分析，
but i think what you can say is that alfred's sense of christian kingship you know he says it himself it's a burden it weighs very very heavily on his shoulders and why i find him a moving an admirable figure is that he shoulders this weight to heroic effect yeah and i think that you know when if he does stand before his savior he could quite legitimately say i have i've did best I could. Because Wessex becomes a great and powerful and wealthy kingdom. And the people of Wessex live at peace in a way that they had not done for decades. And in due course, this kingdom will become the basis for what will become the unitary state of England. Let's talk about that in just a sec. One more thing from Alfred's reign.
但我认为你可以说的是，阿尔弗雷德对基督教君主统治的理解——正如他自己所说——是一个沉重的负担，它非常、非常沉重地压在他的双肩上。为什么我觉得他是一个令人动容、令人钦佩的人物，是因为他以英雄般的效果扛起了这个重担。是的，而且我认为，如果他真的站在他的救世主面前，他可以非常理直气壮地说：“我已经尽力而为。”因为威塞克斯变成了一个伟大、强大且富裕的王国。威塞克斯的人民过上了几十年来从未有过的和平生活。假以时日，这个王国将成为未来英格兰统一国家的基础。我们稍后再谈这个。关于阿尔弗雷德统治时期，还有一件事。
The Alfred jewel, Tom. So that's something a lot of people will be familiar with. In the Ashmolean, isn't it? This magnificent relic of what appears to be of Alfred's reign. It's in the Ashmolean Museum in Oxford. Scholars have hypothesized that the jewel comes from these special sort of reading sticks, these pointers that Alfred had sent out across the land with copies of a book by Pope Gregory the Great. And because on what might be the pointer in the Ashmolean Museum,
阿尔弗雷德珠宝，汤姆。这是许多人都很熟悉的东西。在阿什莫林博物馆，对吧？这是似乎属于阿尔弗雷德统治时期的宏伟遗物。它位于牛津的阿什莫林博物馆。学者们假设这件珠宝来自那种特殊的阅读棍，也就是阿尔弗雷德派遣到全国各地、附带教皇大格里哥利一世著作副本的指针。因为在阿什莫林博物馆的那根可能是指针的东西上，
there's the old English inscription, Alfred McHit Gwirkan. Is it something like that? Is that my old English? Not very good. It's sounding good. Better than my as good as my portuguese probably not alfred ordered me to be made and and this is we think this is definitely
上面有古英语铭文：“Alfred McHit Gwirkan”。是类似这样的话吗？那是我的古英语吗？不太好。听起来不错。比我的好，和我的葡萄牙语差不多。大概是“阿尔弗雷德命令我被制作”，而且我们认为这绝对是
alfred as in king alfred tom i think that's the consensus yeah yeah so that's probably the best single apart from the existence of all these towns is that probably the most spectacular relic of alfred's reign do you think the alfred jewel i think it's the most spectacular relic of Alfred's reign, do you think? The Alfred Jewel? I think it's the most moving and beautiful. I mean, I think the fortifications of Wareham are actually probably the most impressive. And also there's one in London, Queen's Hive, which is basically, if you think of the embankment in the city of London, it's very kind of linear. But there is a kind of indentation, which is the marker of the docks that were repaired by Alfred. So it's called Queen's Hive after Matilda, as in Stephen and Matilda who arrived there.
阿尔弗雷德，也就是阿尔弗雷德国王，汤姆，我认为这是共识。是的，是的。所以这可能是除了所有这些城镇的存在之外，阿尔弗雷德统治时期最壮观的遗物。你觉得呢，阿尔弗雷德珠宝？我认为它是阿尔弗雷德统治时期最壮观的遗物，你觉得呢？阿尔弗雷德珠宝？我认为它是最感人和美丽的。我的意思是，我认为韦勒姆的防御工事实际上可能才是最令人印象深刻的。还有伦敦的一个地方，昆斯海夫（Queen's Hive），基本上，如果你想想伦敦城的泰晤士河堤，它非常具有线性。但有一个凹陷处，那是阿尔弗雷德修复的码头的标志。所以它以玛蒂尔达的名字命名为昆斯海夫，就像到达那里的斯蒂芬和玛蒂尔达一样。
But it was originally called Athelred's Hive. And I'd have to check, but I assume that that's, you know, Athelred, who's the husband of Athelflad. So, you know, there are the trace elements of Alfred across southern England. But of course, his greatest achievement is the existence of England, I think. I think he is the founding father of England. Let's talk about that a little bit. So he dies in 899, and there's no England. There's still just Wessex, right?
但它最初被称为埃塞尔雷德海夫。我还得核实一下，但我假设那是，你知道的，埃塞尔雷德，也就是埃塞尔弗莱德的丈夫。所以，你知道的，整个英格兰南部都留下了阿尔弗雷德的痕迹。但当然，他最伟大的成就，我认为是英格兰的存在。我认为他是英格兰的开国元勋。我们稍微谈谈这一点。所以他在899年去世，当时还没有英格兰。依然只有威塞克斯，对吧？
So to what extent? We know very little about, really, compared with we have that amazing ass's life of alfred um and we have very and we have reasonably detailed accounts in the anglo-saxon chronicle but we know comparatively little about edward his son or athelstan his grandson the rest is history world cup champion in the rest of history's world cup of kings to what extent do you think alfred's reputation is actually resting on the shoulders of those two and and i guess um what's her name uh at the flat yeah because if they hadn't pushed the vikings back further if they hadn't built on all this then we wouldn't even be talking about alfred the great would we of course um he is the founding father
所以从什么程度上来说？与我们拥有那部令人惊叹的阿瑟版《阿尔弗雷德传》相比，我们了解得其实非常少，而且我们在《盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史》中的记载也相对详细，但我们对他的儿子爱德华或孙子埃塞尔斯坦了解得相对较少，其余的都是历史了，就像国王世界杯里的世界杯冠军一样。你认为阿尔弗雷德的声誉在多大程度上实际上是建立在那两个人的肩膀上，以及还有……我想叫什么名字来着？埃塞尔弗莱德，是的。因为如果他们没有进一步将维京人击退，如果他们没有在这一切的基础上继续发展，那么我们甚至都不会谈论“大帝阿尔弗雷德”了，对吧？当然，
but they also are founding fathers and athelflaed is a founding mother and i think that you know if you're english and you're happy that england exists you can be grateful that three generations of rulers were probably the most able kings most able rulers that england has had i mean they were astonishingly able, astonishingly tough. Boris and Liz Truss. I mean, just, you know, look at Athelstan and Athelflad and weep with the comparison. You know, but these are, that's not to sugarcoat them. These were very tough, brutal figures, but they were figures who felt themselves to be laboring in a great cause. As much as Alfred was, these were very devoutly
但他也是开国元勋，埃塞尔弗莱德也是开国元勋（国母），我认为，如果你是英国人并且为英格兰的存在感到高兴，你就会感激三代统治者，他们可能是英格兰有史以来最能干的国王、最能干的统治者。我的意思是，他们惊人地能干，惊人地顽强。鲍里斯和莉兹·特拉斯。我的意思是，只要看看埃塞尔斯坦和埃塞尔弗莱德，然后与他们对比一下，简直令人叹息。但是这些人，这并不是要粉饰他们。这些是非常强硬、残酷的人物，但他们是觉得自己在为一项伟大事业而奋斗的人物。正如阿尔弗雷德一样，这些都是非常虔诚的
christian who felt called upon by you know given the responsibility by god to create and to defend and to preserve their kingdom from heathen men yeah and they do that to spectacular effect and to enduring effect and so you don't think at all that this is all Victorian propaganda? No, I don't. Because that's definitely, so you mentioned earlier on, some people might find that a bit weird if they don't follow academic disputes on Twitter, which I advise you not to do. Because you mentioned the phrase Anglo-Saxon, which has now become incendiary in America and American academia. People don't want to call them. They don't even want to call them the Anglo-Saxons, do they? Yeah. So the word Anglo-Saxon has different significations in different countries. So here it means the Anglo-Saxons. It's the period,
基督徒，他们感到自己受到召唤——鉴于上帝赋予的责任——去创建、捍卫和保护他们的王国免受异教徒的侵害。是的，他们以惊人的效果和持久的效果做到了这一点。所以你根本不认为这全是维多利亚时代的宣传吗？不，我不认为。因为那绝对是……所以你刚才提到，有些人可能会觉得这有点奇怪，如果他们不关注推特上的学术争端的话——我建议你们最好别去关注。因为你提到了“盎格鲁-撒克逊”这个词，它现在在美洲和美国学术界已经成了点燃怒火的导火索。人们不想称呼他们。他们甚至不想称呼他们为“盎格鲁-撒克逊人”，对吧？是的。所以“盎格鲁-撒克逊”这个词在不同的国家有不同的含义。在这里，它指的是盎格鲁-撒克逊人。它基本上是指
basically. It's shorthand for the period between the Roman withdrawal from Britain and 1066. It's been that for a long time. And in France or in Germany or the continent, Anglo-Saxon basically means english speak the english speaking in france it means margaret thatcher and mcdonald's doesn't it exactly kind of liberal free market economics yeah but but there is the use of anglo-saxon as you know britain america australia new zealand so on canada the the anglosphere yeah might be another way of putting it in america you know the word wasps white ang Anglo-Saxon Protestants, there's a sense there that it is used to connote a kind of the 19th century, well, white's a desire to get rid of the very word. It's seen as providing succor to racists in America. But because America is an imperial country and preponderant, there is an absolute assumption among, I think, too many American academics that their use of a word should have global resonance.
罗马人撤出不列颠到1066年之间的这段时期。很长一段时间以来一直如此。而在法国、德国或欧洲大陆，“盎格鲁-撒克逊”基本上是指说英语的人。在法国，它指的是玛格丽特·撒切尔和麦当劳，对吧？完全是那种自由市场经济的自由放任主义。但是，的确有将“盎格鲁-撒克逊”作为——你知道的，英国、美国、澳大利亚、新西兰、加拿大等等，也就是盎格鲁世界（Anglosphere），这可能是另一种表达方式。在美国，你知道“WASPs”这个词，即白人盎格鲁-撒克逊新教徒（White Anglo-Saxon Protestants），人们有一种感觉，它被用来暗指19th世纪的一种……嗯，白人想要彻底抛弃这个词的愿望。在美国，它被视为在为种族主义者提供支持。但由于美国是一个帝国国家且居于支配地位，我认为有太多美国学者有一种绝对的假设，即他们对一个词的使用应该具有全球共鸣。
And they don't acknowledge the fact, firstly, that in England, Anglo-Saxon has the connotation that it does. It does not connote racist supremacy. We have the English Defence League. We don't have the Anglo-Saxon Defence League. And they want to call it early English. English is a much more problematic word in the context of early medieval history. But the other problem with banning the word Anglo-Saxon is it ignores the fact, as we said, that Alfred is using Anglo-Saxon as in his charters. And it's a word that underpins his entire sponsorship of the idea of the Anglican, the idea of Angles and Saxons being part of a unitary kingdom, a unitary people that in the long run will give birth to england and this is this
他们没有承认这样一个事实：首先，在英国，“盎格鲁-撒克逊”具有它所具有的内涵。它并不暗指种族主义至上。我们有“英格兰防卫同盟”（English Defence League），我们没有“盎格鲁-撒克逊防卫同盟”。他们想称其为“早期英语”。在早期中世纪历史的语境下，“英语”是一个问题大得多的词。但禁止“盎格鲁-撒克逊”这个词的另一个问题在于，它忽视了这样一个事实，正如我们所说，阿尔弗雷德在他的宪章中就在使用“盎格鲁-撒克逊”。正是这个词支撑了他对“Anglican”（盎格鲁人）这一概念的所有赞助，即盎格鲁人和撒克逊人是一个统一王国、统一民族的一部分的理念，从长远来看，这将孕育出英格兰，而这
this is looking forward to the future but it's also rooted in the past because it's drawing on beads great work you know he's writing in northumbria the angling kingdom of northumbria um a long time before alfred so the the word anglo-saxon seems to me by far the best description of this very complicated period and and it seems insane to try and get rid of it anyway that's my rant no no i can tom i could not agree with you more you've never had a better rant on this podcast in this series and as all as so often why get rid of it's bonkers to get rid of the term that is natural to most people i think there is a certain a kind of cultural cringe on the part of too many academics in Britain to truckle to American hegemony.
这是在展望未来，但它也扎根于过去，因为它借鉴了贝德的伟大著作，你知道的，他在诺森比亚——那个早在阿尔弗雷德很久之前就存在的诺森比亚盎格鲁王国——写作。因此在我看来，“盎格鲁-撒克逊”这个词依然是对这个极其复杂的时期最好的描述，试图废除它简直是疯了。总之，这就是我的长篇大论。不，不，我完全同意你，汤姆。在这个系列中，你从来没有发表过比这更好的长篇大论了，而且就像往常一样，为什么要废除它呢？废除这个对大多数人来说都很自然的术语简直太疯狂了。我认为，英国有太多学者存在一种文化自卑，去向美国的霸权卑躬屈膝。
They are, in a way, they need to decolonize themselves, to coin a phrase. They need to stop behaving like colonial subjects and assuming that what happens in America should automatically determine what happens here. I couldn't agree with you more, Tom. I mean, you know, I could not agree with you more. So Alfred the Great, when does he get that label, the great? Well, we said in the first, he gets it, I think in around the 13th century, he's first called it. Yeah. And you think it's, and you clearly do think it's justified.
从某种意义上说，他们需要“去殖民化”，借用一个词。他们需要停止表现得像殖民地臣民一样，并想当然地认为美国发生的事情应该自动决定这里发生的事情。我不能再同意你的看法了，汤姆。我的意思是，你知道的，我完全赞同你的观点。那么大帝阿尔弗雷德，他是何时获得“大帝”这个称号的呢？嗯，我们说过在第一期节目中，他大约在13世纪左右首次获得了这个称号。是的。而且你认为，而且你显然认为这是实至名归的。
Well, we've, you know, our first ever episode, we discussed, you know, greatness. Is it a worthwhile term? It's, you know, all ever episode we discussed you know greatness is it is it a worthwhile term it's you know all that kind of stuff i think if you're going to call it a king great in british history i would go for alfred greater than athelstan who won our world cup i think so to the degree that um the scale of the challenge that faces alfred is that much greater so if you're going to be a great king you need a great challenge yeah and we also know more we know much more about alfred and we know all the stuff about the about the reading and about the books and about you know his interest in the church now that's not to say that alfred
我们……在我们有史以来的第一集里，我们讨论了“伟大”。这是一个有价值的术语吗？这是……你知道的，在我们有史以来的第一集里，我们讨论了“伟大，它是一个有价值的术语吗？这……你知道的，所有诸如此类的事情。如果你要在英国历史上称呼一位国王为“伟大”，我会选择阿尔弗雷德，他比赢得我们世界杯的埃塞尔斯坦还要伟大，我认为，从阿尔弗雷德所面临的挑战的规模来看，要大得多。所以，如果你想成为一位伟大的国王，你需要一个巨大的挑战，是的。而且我们也知道得更多，我们对阿尔弗雷德了解得更多，我们知道所有关于阅读、书籍以及他对教会兴趣的事情。这并不是说阿尔弗雷德
didn't have those things too but we just don't know so much about them it's harder it's harder to to construct a sense of athelstan's reign although they're not impossible the other difference i suppose is that alfred has the underdog story doesn't he and athelstan is an overdog he literally becomes the overlord of britain yeah whereas um alfred hiding out in the marshes with his cakes i mean that's a more attractive trajectory i i mean it's that there's the inherent drama of the well the return of the king um you know and alfred alfred literally means you know cancelled by the elves so i think there is a kind of an allure of glamour to it that perhaps i mean athelstan does have athelstan is a glamorous figure but i think the glamour of alfred is is something else and that's why he is a figure
没有这些经历，只是我们对它们了解得没那么多。这更难，更难构建对埃塞尔斯坦统治时期的感知，尽管并非不可能。另一个区别我猜是阿尔弗雷德拥有“弱者逆袭”的故事，对吧？而埃塞尔斯坦是一个强者，他字面意义上成为了不列颠的最高统治者。是的，而阿尔弗雷德带着他的蛋糕藏在沼泽里，我的意思是，这是一个更有吸引力的发展轨迹。我的意思是，这里面有天然的戏剧性——“王者归来”，你知道的，而且阿尔弗雷德的名字字面意思就是“被精灵保护的人”（或类似含义，此处按原意处理），所以我觉得它有一种迷人的魅力，也许……我的意思是，埃塞尔斯坦也具有迷人的魅力，但我认为阿尔弗雷德的魅力是完全不同的，这就是为什么他是一个
who tends to be known by people even if they know nothing about history yeah they know about cakes they have a big sense of him being great. Yes. Alfred the Cake has 1066 and all that. And just a word on the Vikings before we wrap up. Do you think there would have been an England without the Vikings? Impossible to say, isn't it? But there's no question that the destruction of the other three major kingdoms of Anglo-Saxon England make the conquests of Wessex much simpler over the course
即使对历史一无所知的人也往往会了解的人物。是的，他们知道烤焦蛋糕的故事，他们对他的伟大有着强烈的感知。是的，“蛋糕阿尔弗雷德”甚至出现在《1066年及所有那类事》（1066 And All That）这本书里。在我们在结束前谈谈维京人之前，先说一句。你认为如果没有维京人，还会有一个英格兰吗？很难说，对吧？但毫无疑问的是，盎格鲁-撒克逊英格兰其他三个主要王国的毁灭，使得威塞克斯在
of the 10th century yeah uh you know there are there is no east anglian king there is no mercy and king there is no northumbering king to stand in the way first of edward and then of athelstan because there's an argument isn't there that when you look at the beginning of the i don't know 9th century or whatever and you look at the map of what becomes great of the island of great britain it's not obvious that there'll be three different 2000 years or whatever, and you look at the map of the island of Great Britain, it's not obvious that there'll be three different 2000 years or whatever. There'll be three places called Scotland, England, and Wales. They could have evolved very differently. So this does bear on Scotland, obviously, as well, because Northumbria had originally stretched up to the Firth of Forth. And the first use of the word England is applied to Lothian. So that's a reminder stretches of what become Scotland had not become part of
10th世纪期间的征服变得简单得多。是的……你知道的，没有了东盎格利亚国王，没有了麦西亚国王，没有了诺森比亚国王来阻挡起初的爱德华和后来的埃塞尔斯坦，因为有一种观点认为，当你看看……我不知道是9世纪初还是什么时候，当你看着日后成为伟大不列颠岛屿的地图时，并不显而易见会有三个不同的……两千年或者无论多少时间，当你看着大不列颠岛的地图时，并不显而易见会有三个不同的地方分别叫苏格兰、英格兰和威尔士。它们本来可能以非常不同的方式演变。所以这显然也与苏格兰有关，因为诺森比亚最初曾一直延伸到福斯湾。而“英格兰”这个词的首次使用是被应用于洛锡安地区。所以这是一个提醒，如果那些日后成为苏格兰的土地当时没有成为苏格兰的一部分，那么苏格兰可能就不会作为一个讲英语的国家出现。是的，非常有趣。而且如此多的事情都取决于这段时期，它们——我的意思是，这是一个如此基础的时期。我知道每当我们在学校里讨论人们应该学习什么时，你总是说你觉得很疯狂，为什么英格兰的每个人都不学习这个特定的、历史上的这一时刻。我想如果你要上中学，这将是一个很好的起点，然后再去学1066年。是的。这样你就既有了英格兰是如何被创建的故事，又有了1066年的宏伟戏剧。而且，你知道的，“大帝阿尔弗雷德”和“征服者威廉”，这是每个人都应该了解的两位顶级国王。
Scotland then Scotland would be would probably not have emerged as an English-speaking nation yeah interesting very and so many things turn on this period and they I mean it's such a foundational I know you always say that when we because when we talk about what should people study in school you always say that you think it's mad that everybody in England doesn't study this particular, this moment in history. I think if you're going to secondary school, this would be a great place to start and then do 1066. Yeah. So that you have the story of how England's created and then the great drama of 1066. And, you know, Alfred the Great and William the Conqueror, two top kings that everyone should know about.
苏格兰，那么苏格兰可能就不会作为一个讲英语的国家崛起了。是的，非常有趣，很多事情都取决于这段时期。我的意思是这是一个如此基础的……我知道你每次谈到人们在学校应该学习什么时总是这么说，你总是说你觉得奇怪，为什么英格兰的每个人都不学习这个特定的历史时刻。我认为如果你要上中学的，这将是一个很好的起点，然后再学习1066年。是的。这样你就既有了英格兰是如何建立的故事，又有了1066年的宏大戏剧。而且，你知道的，阿尔弗雷德大帝和征服者威廉，是每个人都应该了解的两位顶级国王。
A very good king and a very bad man, I think it's fair to say. All right. So, Tom, have you any more to say about Alfred the Great or are you spent? No, I'm done. Excellent. So I think we should end with another lovely reading. Do you think that'd be nice, Tom? That'd be lovely.
一个是非常好的国王，一个是非常坏的人，我认为这样说很公平。好吧。那么，汤姆，关于大帝阿尔弗雷德你还有什么要说的吗？还是说你已经说完了？不，我说完了。太棒了。所以我觉得我们应该以另一段精彩的朗读来结束。你觉得那样会很好吗，汤姆？那会很棒的。
So this is from the very end of alfred the great section in this absolutely tremendous book which i cannot recommend too highly because i wrote it adventures in time fury of the vikings if you're aged between 8 and 12 or indeed 8 and 100 this is the book for you so here we go when athelstan died in the autumn of 939 the task of building a united christian england was not yet finished. Northumbria in particular had thousands of Danish speakers who still worshipped at the feet of Odin, Thor and Freya. Yet Alfred and his heirs had shown that the Vikings could be beaten. And in fighting off the invaders from the seas, they had created something that would never die. They hadn't just created a
这段话摘自这本绝对棒极了的书——《大帝阿尔弗雷德》这一节的最后，这本书我怎么推荐都不为过，因为是我写的——《时间冒险：维京人的怒火》（Adventures in Time: Fury of the Vikings）。如果你年龄在8到12岁之间，或者实际上在8到100岁之间，这就是适合你的书。所以我们开始吧：当埃塞尔斯坦在939年秋天去世时，建立一个统一的基督教英格兰的任务尚未完成。诺森比亚尤其有成千上万的讲丹麦语的人，他们仍然在奥丁、索尔和弗蕾亚脚下顶礼膜拜。然而，阿尔弗雷德和他的继承人已经证明了维京人是可以被击败的。在击退来自海洋的入侵者的过程中，他们创造了一种永不消亡的东西。他们创造的不仅仅是
vision of England, They had written one of the greatest underdog stories in all history. So don't laugh, Tom. Can boys and girls learn from this? Wait, wait, wait. They had written one of the greatest underdog stories in all history. The story of a king who found his hope in a peasant's hut and a people who found their courage. The story of a nation battered, bruised and yet unbowed, who found a fighting spirit they never knew they had. And somehow, at the end of it all, came through to victory. Wow. That is the reading we need now.
一个英格兰的愿景，他们还写下了整部历史中最伟大的“弱者逆袭”的故事之一。所以别笑，汤姆。男孩女孩们能从中学到东西吗？等等，等等，等等。他们写下了整部历史中最伟大的“弱者逆袭”的故事之一。一个在农夫简陋小屋里找到希望的国王的故事，以及一个找回勇气的民族的故事。一个遭受重创、伤痕累累却依然不屈不挠的民族的故事，他们发现了一种连自己都不知道自己拥有的战斗精神。不知何故，在这一切的最后，他们迎来了胜利。哇。这正是我们现在需要的朗读。
Bye bye. Bye bye. That is the reading we need now. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
再见。再见。这正是我们现在需要的朗读。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取独家节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点点八卦的地方。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家节目以及提前购买现场门票的权利，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。